and here we go so you don't have to wait
any longer that people were waiting for
Magnus versus all they raise it now they
get it it is game one Magnus with the
white pieces he adopts a pretty solid
setup so far nothing too major has
happened but that D4 Square black can
sink a knight in there that could be
good news
I just learned something so quick
already I mean you know I'm a kid
specialist and I love King's Indian I
just won he's a strong I am in my last
tournament you know a ID for life right
is what we say but what he did was he
moved his knight from f8 around to E6
very quickly got the mine over to H7 so
it was pretty quiet
just holding everything it's a game of
night Maneuvers that night went from E6
to C7 and it's up to B5 now so it can't
stop won't stop the night continues it's
tour of this board and now the white
Knight's turn to improve itself
lots of maneuvering G4 Knight F3 Bishop
G4 there oh right
so I feel like black is doing quite
nicely look at this activity for the
pieces oh G5 fell off but was that a
blunder or a sacrifice
yeah because he didn't move instantly I
think it was a blunder but I mean he did
find something out of that he's still
doing oh my goodness King's in here for
the win we don't ever have to play
another opening King's Indian for the
win once again can we get some kid in a
chat he's Indian defense I'm always a
special
who likes King's Indian defense this
one's a wrap it's that Queen is trapped
let's go up to E2 then you force the
Queens off and you win the ensuing end
game Magnus resigns he doesn't want to
test alirez's mouth speed he knows that
it would be over so Ali Reza faruja is
the first player on the scoreboard he
gets up one to nothing and now in game
two Magnus he's given up a pawn will he
get it back
uh his question here is Willie get it uh
okay
I do like wise position here the space I
mean it's just Advantage you got to
clean the E3 everything's defended then
he attacks on again castles like hey G4
hey
you know what that night on E7 is that
really a knight that doesn't look like
the pony that kids dream about that
might can't go anywhere oh but those
pawns are all dropping off
G5 takes uh yep Agnes is back
I don't think he's gonna let this one
slip but if you take this bishop on C3
then white takes the Knight on E7 and
then there's Nike G5 ideas that King is
in trouble and now b7's gone that gives
way to pass oh my goodness bro
it's about to be a 2-0 frozen relax you
know this Magnus right like you know
this is Magnus I mean I don't know if
you know that like this Magnet or else
it's maybe he's winning now there it is
yeah okay he's like yeah he resigned no
you get this one it's two nothing and
another reminder that we are 45 minutes
of bullet chess in the matches in the
winner semifinals and Beyond in the
winners bracket so uh this gives Magnus
more time even if he loses this game he
has a little bit more time to catch up
sometimes James people need to find
their Rhythm they just can't find their
form from the start
right it does take some time there we do
have actually mvl in the gym oh
dog is uh he's going for
for the um
for Ali Reza's there I think we can
probably see four interesting yeah
what's Happening Here looks like The
Rook just has to back up and the A6 Pawn
that is going to be a long-term Target
so Magnus is trying to coordinate his
pieces and shout out to mvl one of the
best chess players in history a former
World Blitz Champion uh he's had so many
successes to his name but he's rooting
for his compatriot that Alaris plays for
friends bam Bishop H2 check will follow
if the Knight where to move so Ali Rizza
just won a piece he's probably thanking
his friend Maxime for stopping by
got a little freeze there
and we're back
hey what happened actually uh internet I
think we're good
you're good James I think we're good I
think we're good here what happened in
this last game here oh Ali bro what no
that yeah it's two to one right no no no
no I'll let Reza won again he doesn't
stop winning that's what's happening
wait
is this really 3-0 it's 3-0 it is it's
not a typo that's not a typo
Robert let me ask you again Robert is
this typo or like I mean my internet
went out a little bit
it you know it's not a typo
Magnus has not won a game in the first
three he's trying to win this fourth one
yeah you crazy
I don't believe it I don't believe it I
gotta go back and watch the VOD oh oh
what Max allows E7 the past Pawn can go
up but otherwise it doesn't play at
first and now the e-pawn is it's gone
okay so if he's back in the game I was
just kind of Silent here because I was
just looking at like bro Magnus how
three games what if you lose another one
then I'm like I'm gonna be over here
sweating like I'm playing like literally
oh yeah that's just nice yeah he's
winning now Magnus
yeah his Bishop's protected by the rook
and so now he is up one Pawn but very
importantly the white king is in danger
and the H2 Pawn That's essential you
need to keep that one and black has
gained a passer
hey
whoa push push oh we can win this is
just over summer just hit the button
resign there and respect right but I'm
gonna keep playing it play it out yeah
he resigned now whatever the clock by
the way Magnus finished that game up 15
seconds like he played fast he played
well and he put pressure on Furious both
on the board and on the clock
I am uh very impressed I mean I think
everyone is right now I think everyone I
think everybody's on the edge of their
seats seeing farrugia Oh three oh whoa
hey man hold on bro this is like that's
supposed to be cool this is definitely
was um was crazy I mean to see I'm
excited to see the rest of this
obviously 23 maybe five take take it's
all Theory H3 yeah yeah
but this is the type of theater that I
know puts you to sleep you're like come
on we're the tactinos
exactly for breakfast lunch and dinner
and this was none of those in this game
but of course I could have tried B6 C6
just to keep the pawn as a wedge there
but it might be weak after C5 whatever
for the game right but still uh very
theoretical Rigby why
oh my goodness he wants to trade because
E4 is now loose and it's grabbed and
that's an extra Pawn for farugia
Oh lyrics takes takes is this not Knight
C4 F3 Knight F6 takes takes d5's hanging
E6 is hanging they both hang in there it
might be draw you know he can definitely
draw these type of positions but bullet
changes everything up it does I'm
looking at the clock so of course we see
the eval bar suggesting that fuja is
better but I'm looking at the time and
Magnus up a couple seconds so he's going
to use that to his Advantage you can't
afford a night trade that's why he drops
his Knight back so we're just doing this
perfectly just go after white pawns and
get a bit more active
look at that Magnus getting Magnus you
know what I mean like when do you ever
see that Magnus getting Magnus in the
end game right now it's still chances
for a draw Still chances very difficult
just move that's all you have to do if
you're Max look at the clock I don't
think all the reason has enough time to
convert this advantage
this is a moment of silence
like I gotta see if he's gonna convert
this oh man check move okay yeah yeah
doing good progress farouza he's almost
there Magnus paused which was probably
not a good thing to do there at that
moment oh now farooja has it he's mating
oh my goodness this guy is unreal um
relax and Magnus is frustrated you could
see it on his face that deep sigh of
just like what do I have to do to
survive against this youngster but
farouza he's determined you know he
wants to win
yeah he's uh I mean he's he is ready to
be Magnus here in front of everyone he's
trying to now obviously Magnus it's it's
a lot of time left 36 minutes but
alireza is up three games right now and
he's in great form very hot we're gonna
see what happens here wow this is crazy
to see okay so Focus takes takes Rook D1
we need seven everything equalish yeah
opposite colored Bishops but White's
Queen is it's annoying to the black
pawns on the queen side so everything
protected in the position for both
players I don't see a single weakness
and now the pieces are coming off so as
you said equalish is probably leaning
towards Josh
bullet changes everything too like that
one mistake in the end game on move 46
when you should have went King E6
instead of King D6 now you're zugged out
you have a rescue page 820 right you
actually like then you lose in the
bullet game like it's crazy the higher
level
and I mean we agree with that by a ninja
26 this should be broadcast in every
existing screen in the world uh yeah
this is two of the best players of all
time to the best players currently who
are now going to try to flag each other
they'll probably just make a repetition
in a bishop of opposite color ending so
the draw has happened repetition and
that means that ferrugia keeps his
three-game lead how is Magnus going to
take all the reason down that is what we
need to see before we can believe in
magnus's chances
oh yeah that's right yeah we're gonna
see a lot of gold D5 whoa that is not
familiar with that
it was some recent Theory with this oh
yeah it was July Orton Jordan right
Jordan van for us it's like some
interesting stuff
lyrics C1 I'm Bishop C2 or Bishop T5 E4
doesn't care about any of that yeah
white has the center but black is the
bishop pair and you mentioned Air Jordan
who's been a second for uh Magnus before
and look at these pawns what is
happening in the center of the board
Rook takes E5 there's G4 blocking the
PIN
oh that's nice I could have taken I have
three first queen F3 hits F7 so he takes
now he goes for it anyway I'll Rook D5
yeah oh my goodness so many tactics yeah
but white has to be better here look at
this you're going on the attack on the
offensive Rook C6 comes to mind and it's
played
and that was a past Pawn D7 Rooks
yeah he's feeling good there we go
Magnus back yeah Magnus back there
that's a dub because the black king can
reach E7 but there's Knight C6 check at
the end and we're seeing something like
it uh I think others will just resign in
a couple moves or maybe uh there is the
resolution I'll say maybe he's thinking
about match strategy let's play these
now it's too early in the match we're
still 34 minutes remaining but you know
in the back of his head he's like all
right I have the lead maybe I should
burn some of the clock
all right maybe he's a burst my clock
here and then we have a French man
another friendship Magnus we're playing
a lot of this lately actually
Frenchies
I hate giving up that light Square
Bishop but that is Theory I like going
more Bishop D3 to keep it and queen E2
here same position but we still have a
bishop here I'm with you everything I
love that light score Bishop in the
French but uh it looks like Ollie raises
says I'm just gonna lead in development
but Magnus has found a way to Castle so
he has the bishop pair and if you get E5
next followed by Bishop E6 then suddenly
we're talking about an advantage for
black with open space
that's what he did does as well he goes
back to C3 instead of Queen D5 check
allowing Bishop E6 I mean C3 take take
Bishop F5 and this is a fine French this
is kind of annoying when you get the
French like this black definitely has
some nice chances himself he might have
G4
it before there uh it was Queens bring
something to C4 bring your Rooks in the
game and I guess white has a pawn
advantage on the queen side three on two
but black has such a nice Central Pawn
E5 and I don't see how white makes any
initial progress
very difficult to do that oh that's a
nice night on D5
but it's only a good night it just looks
great the episode c66 that was beautiful
G4 man look at the this is the Magnus
work Magnus working there pieces on the
greatest squares King on F5 can't really
do anything nothing runs in at some
point F6 is defended this was clinical
way to do it here it comes King E4 King
F3 and that should be that okay F5 is a
nice move to include But Here Comes the
black king F4 check he load F4 check
oh my goodness anymore
he hated it you can see it in his face
he's losing what is this bro this
doesn't make any sense takes takes this
will a chest look at the clock speaking
of bull chest Magnus is ahead on time so
he's losing by position because he was
doing all that funny business but he's
actually oh is he ahead not for long now
he's behind
four seconds here remove Primo pre-move
everything's removed from this why not
yeah he's gone oh
oh you know this Rook what is gonna
happen oh he Flags he hits the table he
smiles oh this is about to get serious
oh man he mad now he mad now my goodness
it's about to get crazy
gave away his Rook because he was
essentially pre-moving Magnus took the
Rook but didn't have enough time
remaining to steal the last few pawns
and secure a draw so farouza gets
another Win Mag slams the table he gives
a smile though because I think he
appreciates it right you know he's like
all right respect Young fella
yeah yeah he's definitely mad and it is
respect because he said you know even
the world championship like hey look I'm
not interested unless from playing
farrugia here so he always has this Peru
you know I mean everybody is challenged
there but man
Russia is up you know three games on
Magnus like his nothing the Magnus
malding oh man this is crazy this I've
never seen this
never seen this I don't think Chad has
either Magnus is simply down upon right
now but F5 is a good move the black king
cannot enter back on the e-file there'll
be rookie one check with a skewer so
White's trying to push the pawn go king
of four and look at the clock that oh
there is just burned suddenly Magnus is
up like eight seconds and now the
advantage is also heading back towards
his Direction
yeah it's looking good here takes takes
I mean he's getting the right positions
what's the time okay so he's up 10
seconds oh how is that losing you
kidding me what great move by foreign
I thought it was White's move I thought
there was like a pre-move but it was
Black's turn after Rook h8 so both sides
are just queened wait what's happening
Rook see it and take on C4
what happened oh he's back in the game
oh man bullet is unreal I don't know I'm
not over here sweating like I'm playing
like this is wow this is so crazy to see
okay B6 Z I'll take yeah yeah let's go
to the a file so what magazine do is
pre-move like non-stop he should go King
A2 he he went Pac-Man but he couldn't
win King A2 King A1 and so on but that
was crazy James because ferrugia was
completely winning and then Magnus you
know he just took all the tricks out of
his bag and he he saved one
right he saved one there he definitely
got away I would breathe a little bit
all right who I can breathe because that
was gonna be four points when you get
four not only are you mad but you're
down four points and you're mad you know
that's different that is a different
feel and time is running out I remember
looking at the clock and it said 45
minutes at some point right with 29
minutes guys right I mean we love seeing
these games but the time is eventually
going to run out and someone is going to
be a winner here today right now
Borussia up games on Magnum pregame
insane see what happens
Knight E6 he goes really sad man but it
feels like White's King has no shelter
definitely think so C4 takes on okay
because Queen C6 oh yeah played It
Anyway at three yep
or you have no pieces he did too much
there yep two minor pieces for a rook
and black has well a very safe King and
now the initiative with all these pieces
coming forward so Magnus he needs this
game he's also up 15 plus seconds
that's yes let's go over yeah you can
just resign now this is always the
starting of the game you gotta Crush
that game in fact Magnus yeah it's a mad
Magnus that was a dominating game here
five yeah
and this opening Scandinavian it worked
out for Magnus playing some offbeat
stuff trying to you know keep others out
of his comfort zones but suddenly it
feels like always back in the game
except for the fact that he's so far
down on the clock
eight seconds here and then we will
probably we could see a flag on the
other end
so Rook B1 you get a couple checks
him uh he takes this Rook that was a
very smart move Bishop to B4
is happening H5 doesn't work yet you
don't know what's gonna happen you see
this evil bar going nuts here okay F5
Bishop back up we got material V2 is
hanging not anymore checking those we
check again wait what happened to them
he's pre-moving Magnus is trying to play
very quickly and that's why he's giving
away pieces but we do see that magnet oh
my gosh he's moving too slowly he takes
the queen but he's a little time oh for
Russia gets it
he loses on time
oh did he lose on time bro he did and
you could tell he took one from Taylor
Swift he's trying to shake it off but
for ruja says I don't care how I get the
dub as long as I keep on winning
yo I'm my hand might be going through
the computer if I'm not like here the
whole arm might go through the computer
there wow he whacked him again
I wonder how the internet connection is
out there in Barcelona the hotel that
the chess bras and Magnus are staying at
you know that doesn't seem to be what's
deciding these games but at any moment
you know you need to make sure what
wait wasn't Rook takes D4 a free piece
I thought it was it was what wait there
was yeah that was just free yes it's
free that's for me all right thanks Z4
was definitely moved oh man you can see
he's over here in yeah yeah using the
words whatever that is that's definitely
probably some adult language
wow I'm listening what he said over here
but it is definitely not looking good
right now for me he's just man Russia is
working unbelievable here I really
thought Magnus had the upper hand I'm
gonna lie but I think everyone did
but uh wow got some work to do if he's
gonna come back so what I asked is
feroza even the underdog I actually
didn't think so and he's proving that he
can hang with magazine not just hang
with him he has a big lead and right now
Magnus may be up about eight seconds but
for Russia's up a pawn so I don't know
how to weigh that trade off
yeah oh that was nice that before there
takes takes
wow yeah you gotta draw this okay you
know what let's stop saying that these
games don't you'd be able to draw and
then they flag it's this is anybody's
game even white can win this believe it
or not but the clock situation is you
know it's getting closer to level that's
good news for farouja who's up a pawn
and I think he's he wants to win this
game he's looking at Magnus and saying
you're not quick enough to hang with me
wow wow them words would never come out
of my mouth like I mean unbelievable you
know but right now it is working in
farooza's favor he had two games by flag
and again it doesn't matter how you get
it it matters did you get it done right
so he does oh wait he he moved and he
may not be getting it done here baby boy
and let's see let's see the speed from
from Magnus he's not putting the king in
check at all he needs to put that King
exactly
1.1.1.1 oh and Perugia left his yeah I
already got him
do you think he threw his Mouse where
did he go he probably did
he might have thrown the mouse off
Instinct and like oh my bad I forgot let
me uh Reach In The Box for the next
Mouse because I got a box of mice next
to me because I break a lot of them
point one
wow and for once Magnus steals a victory
I mean that one was ever so close 0.1
seconds left that is all you need to win
a game on time and now we're back to a
three-point deficit and if we look at
this game here it looks like Magnus with
the black pieces has control the open
file he also has a 10 second lead in the
clock so Magnus James he's been jumping
out to the early leads in these games
but then ferrugia speeds up and that's
where he does his damage
and the problem is you know farouza is
not only speeding up but he's playing
Super tricky some stuff is very accurate
and you get these attacks and these
tactics out of nowhere because you know
he's a tactical absolute wizard with
this stuff Perugia is of course the
Magnus can spot attack these two as well
but even in magnus's style he just
doesn't care as much for the opening
advantages he likes to grind it's a slow
chest he can do anything Universal
player oh whatever reason with these
tricks man and the timing thing before
it takes takes that's clinical so
magnets could have traded pieces he said
I don't want trade pieces look at the
pawn structure double isos on f file and
default and The Rook just fell in the
corner so now black is up at full piece
with the safer King bring your knight
into the attack there it is over queen
of Fate watch out cruising seven eight
oh my God
oh at first it might break another mouse
with the heat he shook his hands out let
me shake it off let me stretch and flex
real quick I forgot my name's Matt oh my
goodness farooza did the worst thing
imaginable he took that Rook which was
smart but Magnus saw that coming he's if
I take your Rook I get checkmated when
that pod promotes he ran his King away
and farrugia was pre-moving you can't
pre-move that early I think he himself
would tell you that if you asked him
advice on how to improve as a bullet
player you can't pre-move that early
because when you get hit with an
unexpected move you're the one who's
gonna be in trouble and well we're
looking at trouble for Magnus he just
won a couple games but now he's just a
terrible position from the white side
this is pretty gross but he did
definitely win back and now he's feeling
good I mean I feel hey got some games in
it's a two-game match I make it a
one-game match we can play this forever
of course we don't allow that here with
the format but we would like to see it
and you know people have took off work
for this let's go Rook C3 Rook G3 does
have some type of attack head shake
there from farrugia because look at that
Rook H3 he doesn't want a black Rook to
help in the defense and E3 just look a
calm little move saying you're not going
to take any to a check now the black
king is hunted Queen G7 Queen takes F7
uh there's probably other things oh
Bishop C6 he's even go for the check
just yet
wow because he wants queen D5 after all
that E7 Queen F7 he he blundered in a
lot of Queen trade
jeez
oh no all his pieces are gone and he's
mad he's very very mad I think he's
trying to convince himself that he can
do this by shaking out all those
blunders
shake it out you know what that's that's
what we're doing you check out the bar
all right cool let me shake shoot a lot
of y'all need to hyperventilate shape so
let's get the shakes out if we shaking
the blunders out that's what we're doing
perfect perfect shake it off chat
the new thing
yeah you know what
there's uh the Harlem Shake and then
there's the Magna shake and
you know then there's the chocolate
shake that I want to drink so you know
either either way we look at it it looks
like Magnus he's playing a good game
here Rook D2 his B2 hits F2 and Bishop
A6 is gonna hurt at some point as well
or Rook is on C2 he's been getting a lot
of Rooks to the seventh here taste taste
but should be six very strong
A4 wants A5 looks like maybe Rook to B1
takes on C6 so d8 is hanging Magnus with
a head shape there see a lot of that man
from both sides too but man he's just
really frustrating Magnus
is understandable so
A4 is on a light Square C4 is on a light
Square that's good news when you have a
light Square bishop and down goes upon
version decides the sacrifices to give
Magnus double pawns but this is looking
good for black at the stage and I'm
looking at the clock again Magnus is the
faster player out of the gates but then
ferrugia he gets into that next gear at
some point
yeah I think he started getting into
that next gear after he figures out the
opening that's what I'm saying he's like
oh this will be doing all right cool
then you just start speeding which is
causing some of his demise when it comes
to like that pre-move game where he
sacked the queen it was brilliant and
then you lost immediately afterwards
into the pre-move so here we go
the mouse might be too small for him and
causing him some pain so if we do get an
interview with Magnus we'll have to hear
about it he does actually seem
physically pained that actually does
seem correct 100 and it is important
guys to grab the right Mouse and I'm
sure he knows that I mean it's not his
first time you know he even streams too
as well but we do need to get him
something probably better uh for that I
think he does have some wrist problems
with that it wasn't shaking but then
with the constant of it and it's matched
that can affect
and I like this comment bullet chess is
a dance competition for the eval bar
yeah that thing's going up and down it's
a workout all right a stockfish no they
don't get enough you know they're not
enough challenges here so bullet chess I
will do that and H4 just dropped Knight
comes into G5 I see the eval bar saying
White's only like slightly better I
would initially think this is completely
winning and Magnus is also up 10 seconds
but he made it practical oh but yes uh
yeah and then
having a right Mouse is very important
guys of course I think some of the
flagging was due to the Mouse and his
hand actually cramping probably with the
mouse that he's using you do have to ask
to see what's about that if we could
interview with them but yeah something
definitely think about as we see the
handshake after like every game now and
I'm looking at the clock and every game
it does seem like Magnus is well ahead
and right now he is up nine seconds so
this is where Oliver needs to be careful
you can't just pre-move certain
decisions and Magnus is going for the
win he is decided to Spring free a pass
Pawn
oh
over G7 but he has to stop the same Pawn
first that's smart very strong very
strong that's sick even do you have to
sacrifice try to win the a pawn
and what Mr Dixie five and he goes B3
what a move an A3 Magnus wants to win he
wants to flag the guy
A3 Magnus seven seconds great move
Bishop B5 that is GG yeah that's GG one
diagonal method after that push check
anyone to see Pawn he won yeah
what a game see that's what happens when
you have a lead on the clock you can
take certain risks you can make some
decisions that may not be objectively
the best but in terms of Chess play but
they're objectively best in bullet and
Magnus gets the dub alireza he sees that
his leads shrink to two he's still doing
really well playing great bullet but
James I think we have to say that Magnus
must be feeling good about the
conclusion of that game
Man actually you know what I'm looking
at the feature chat Mouse is the 19th
piece right
the clock and then you need a mouse
right so like it's different that's just
so funny extra piece there whoa what
happened what the hey bro what likes
whoa whoa we was just whoa yeah he's in
pain yeah it really is and I think he's
in pain because he just got his King
slammed off the board with Knight takes
E7 and a fork so uh that's the problem
that Magnus had right now is he gets a
couple wins and then he has like a
really bad loss in there and it's
credited to alireza for just taking it
to him Oliver is a notes he's gonna lose
some games you're playing Magnus Carlson
you're playing bullet chess but I think
he recovers very nicely
yeah absolutely recovery and that comes
with obviously 100 youth having as many
games I mean as Magnus probably like
still as well the youth are um so it's
just very rich you're still playing very
quickly very fast stuff like that too as
well but yeah this is tough magnets with
a headshake again there yeah something
with the mouse a little bit of pain I
think if he had a better Mouse and
wasn't in pain you probably would cease
a better Magnus here too as well this is
amazing that is amazing black is up a
pawn and your coaches tell you trade
while you're ahead he goes to the end
game and he's losing because the A5 Pawn
is on a dark square and White's gonna
Bishop E5 Bishop takes D4 Bishop F2 same
idea take on D4 then win the C3 Pawn
then win the A5 Pawn it's that simple
how crazy is that right when they do
tell you trade when you're up not when
you're down you trade when you're up and
you lose and you like you know what I'm
not ever doing that again right somehow
he is able to run his King over but I
mean practically it still looks very
good for white with the two passwords I
think what happened was that Bishop was
a little bit too close to the black king
saving a vital Tempo and the White Queen
side pawns haven't moved quickly enough
but as you said this is bullet and when
it talking about an end game like this
that still gives white good chances to
win because the black past pawns are not
even pawns anymore they're off the board
yeah this is wait a second I mean wait
um
maybe not B7 Knight takes B7 then A7
that was a oh gross that's it
yeah and a queen and they're back to one
game but you see Magnus again I mean he
is just like in pain he's shaking off
his hand there it doesn't matter if he
wins or loses so it's clearly not a
results based action and well you know I
hope he doesn't get arthritis and carpal
tunnel from playing this match
yeah one match right yeah especially all
the energy there but no we just do we do
it wish him the best it's not uh it's
not fun to play in pain and anything in
fact so it is important that you have
the right ergonomics and the right
settings and setups for long matches
like this which usually has a shaking in
the middle of the game you know what I
mean so this is definitely affecting
this play I think
um so it's important at home guys to get
the right stuff I actually just bought
uh I see some minor chat says razor I
just bought Razer yesterday in fact from
Best Buy because it's like yo you just
get you know the right stuff when you're
playing these online games guys it's
important well Max has the right stuff
and he wants to win because the winner
of this match is guaranteed 12
000 so a lot at stake while the loser
goes down to the losers quarterfinals uh
these guys are good they should play
professionally yeah that's true I think
that would be good advice for them and
right now Magnus with the black side of
this position he's up in exchange he's
trying to trade while ahead but in his
own terms not like last game with frugia
unfortunately stumbled into to a bad end
game
absolutely here as uh hold on everyone
we're moving a little bit but I may have
the exchange practically I'm just
winning practically so I have to work it
as he's doing make sure my improve my
position by moving pieces and pawns
ahead which he's doing
he's doing that
what do you say mouse over everything
okay I like that I like you we about to
get some merch with that Mouse over
everything okay I think Magnus just you
know he wiped that dirt off his
shoulders there like he's like all right
now it's tied match and Magnus is
actually playing more quickly than
alibraza is Right we've seen Max up on
time quite a bit he's lost some of those
time scrambles except when he'd 0.1
seconds remaining so here it's important
for alireza he needs to settle down and
uh oh wait why did that bar go so high
he went really high there after age six
maybe F or something
interesting there's some like H4 G6
Queen H5 stuff it's range yes it's
impossible to figure out with no time
and you're just gonna make these quick
moves at the early stages and give me
that D5 Square says Magnus I'm gonna
plop my pieces down and well if you take
on D5 that's a pass Pawn in the center
fix takes and he holds it holds the E5
Pawn Rick probably swinging the D1 at
some point plays A4 break the structure
down
and I think we're gonna see at some
point Rook D1 Pawn G4 White's Just Gonna
Keep black tied down to the Past Pawn
but I don't think that it's a big
concern so this is good news for oh
there is a the bishop blockades the pawn
The Queen Is Now free to run and running
it it does it goes down to A2 and maybe
into C2
and Rook C2 is going to be quite
annoying that is going to be a very
annoying move we're C2 anyway paper C3
first and they send me to Ava that
allows
I guess he could have played that anyway
s
he does play Queen two F5 is loose I
didn't even realize that I was trying to
trade Queens in an earlier variation but
stealing a pawn don't blunder Checkmate
and oh again he trades when he's ahead
like his coaches always tell him and
somehow that was a bad oh there's was a
rook at fate in Bishop C5 I guess not
yeah not anymore here he's worth walking
the King right he's winning F5 is going
to come with a check before F5 check
take take and we push yeah and we push
walk the dogs in the park very easy push
push push push
and push and that's that Magnus he
throws in the towel he's down five
seconds and a couple pawns I mean he
really is in pain right now you can see
it yeah on his face I think some people
they try to make that excuse right
they're like they're ready if they lose
the match oh something happened but he's
doing it no matter what's happening on
the board and as somebody you know who
does struggle with wrist issues when you
don't have a good Mouse and you're
trying to play speed chess it can really
hurt
oh yeah he'll never have that again and
I think it is this mouse at least or at
least the setup to do that it is
important to have the right Mouse the
right table setting right uh everything
here obviously a mad is good ergonomic
eboard this is important if you want to
have very long longevity in obviously uh
the online space so it's very good to do
that but Know It's just tough love to
see because we know he's in pain right
now
but I think that he's in pain both
physically and on the board in this
position because White's Advantage is
through the roof I think at some point
F5 is going to hurt like just throw your
Pawn forward play in the candy style
that we love right and go for there it
is go for checkmate there it is you know
it's funny you said somebody in the chat
says chess is a dangerous sport bro like
sue you know
this is dangerous man them pawns you
know those kings that hurt you bro you
gotta be careful so it's uh that's a
funny one here but it is important to
definitely work on your game and also
your ergonomics you can play for a long
time nice sacrifice we got an aggressive
position here
E6
that is maybe the move of the day if you
take with the Knight F7 Falls if you
took with a bishop there's a Checkmate
on d8 so he was rookie seven but now
this bishop is pinned and that's amazing
here as well it's my first arrows of the
day that's how good the move was
Brazilian
oh yeah
I love tactics and he does a lot of
those I mean he you know we've seen him
do when he used to stream we would see
him do puzzles and just blow through
puzzles nice to do your puzzle
and now it's under 10 minutes remaining
so Magnus he needs to catch up it is Win
by two this has been very important in
certain matches like in the one between
Jose Martinez and a niche that was the
end of the first day of action but if
Magnuson keep this deficit to one you do
get extra time nine plus minutes
remaining James hit the white pieces
here for Magnus do you believe in his
chances I do believe in his chances here
I do believe uh I mean he's very clutch
Under Pressure he's done this many times
he is playing some very strong
opposition of two games right now but
you know if we don't see it happen in
the next three minutes it's not gonna
happen it's not gonna happen so he does
have time maybe two or three more games
to get this thing really going here
um but you know it's difficult I think
he can do it
yeah so we'll see what it is Mike he
gets in this game he's down a pond but
he has the pair of Bishops that Rook on
Eight's been hanging for a little bit
but some trades occurred first and well
he's really handling himself perfectly
in this match he's playing well in
critical moments he's keeping Pace when
it seems like he's down a bunch of time
and right now he's down a few seconds
but he's catching up
and here we see that the pieces are
coming off the board black still up a
pawn and well it's an extra Pawn on the
a file that's always good news but white
has the bishop and white has the lead on
time so 10 seconds Advantage for Magnus
as he pushes his H Pawn I think he's
just done that well today giving away a
pawn to double his opponent's Pawn
structure and after H5 Falls maybe H6 is
next so this position looks really good
for Max don't put a Checkmate the king
went back so it avoided that and the
king is gonna go back to G2 A7 Falls
King for black needs to come up the
board he only has nine seconds he needs
to gobble those pawns but as long as
Magnus has a rook he should try to flag
his opponent no draw offers this no
don't play that move do not trade Rooks
when your opponent is five seconds that
is probably one of the earliest rules
you learn as a top bullet player Magnus
knows better I think maybe the pressure
of the moment is getting to him just to
acknowledge James is internet Gambit it
happened again so we will get him back
as soon as we can but right now we are
running down the stretch of this match
Magnus Carlson down by two points to
alireza farooza farouza has played an
amazing match thus far he deserves his
lead will he be able to keep it well
he's got a great Center Magnus chisels
at it with Pawn to F6 and we see that
frigid takes an open file his Bishop on
E3 is loose he will not blunder that I
don't believe he brings his next Rook on
over but Magnus finally finishes
development so I think this position it
looks very unclear to my eyes Bishops we
like them in open space against Knights
but the knights are actually causing
some problems and that's why we saw I'll
take the Knight on G6 it was attacking
the bishop on E5 Queen B3 a bad blunder
apparently there must be some tactics
over on the king side against this white
king the king didn't slap to G H2 to
avoid any pressure down the G file the
bishop slides back in touch with the
King Magnus he jettison's a pawn he is
up a couple seconds but that probably
was not the right decision and well
otherwise it says give me a pawn I'll
use that pawn here goes up the a file
the bishop on D3 Hit The Rook it also
stops that Pawn's progress at least for
now and and with the Rooks off the board
that should make others feel safer with
his King his King on H2 tucked away the
black king also saved by that outside
pass Pawn that is a nuisance that
magnets will have to continue to keep
his eye on he is up a few seconds
otherwise they're trying to trade some
pieces he plays B4 he might see Knight
C5 next trying to get those Knights off
the board and there they go but this
outside pass Pawn it's a straggler it's
by itself it doesn't have a companion
but that's checking in one oh my
goodness Magnus Carlson hangs mate in
one and farouza takes a three-point lead
Magnus has enough time right there is
five minutes and 45 seconds remaining in
this match but you cannot give away
Checkmate like that not against farugia
because ferrugia has proved to be a
difficult opponent to defeat under any
circumstance but now when your back is
against the Pervert proverbial wall you
don't have time remaining and it's going
to be a tactical Affair a slope Fest
against fruja you can't afford that but
actually it seems like in this game
Magnus he's getting away with some of
those choices earlier D6 is loose D6 is
a problem and it seems like Knight F6 as
well that's a fork that wins material
and I think you can oh there's a fork of
his own that's why he brought the king
out to F2 and instead he now grabs The
Rook grabs the pawn up a pawn is Magnus
Carlson
also has a 10 second lead on the clock
so he is doing very well in this game he
needs it he cannot afford to let this
Advantage slip he's transitioning into a
several Pawn up rook end game and here's
where Matt's strategy comes under play
what for should do is play this out it
doesn't matter if he's down three queens
you play this out until check and mate
except for user resigned and as soon as
he did we have Canty back James hey you
just missed a Checkmate in one and then
farooza unfortunate for him once he
ballooned that lead to three it's now
back to two because Magnus took that
last game
yep yeah this game right now we see a
position where
um white has stabilized the Knight on D4
uh we just saw a swap of pieces Black's
position A-Okay getting the king out to
H7 there's left for the king and it
looks like Magnus gonna open up the
queen side so you play on both flanks it
seems like hey we do have James back for
real so James we just see Queen F4 it
looks like a mating attack coming down
to H2
absolutely no it was uh yeah I was
saying um that is the time is really low
in fact meaning like three minutes
someone something's gonna happen we're
either going to six game match
or somebody wins here and I mean ruja
has not given up the leads yet it's not
giving up the lead so it's very
difficult to say who's going to win this
yeah right this is looking good to win
it but Magnus needs to do a lot more if
he's going to try to make this boy a tie
breaker this is tough right now and a
few games ago it was Rook against rook
and each side had a pawn and Magnus was
up 15 to five seconds and he allowed to
draw do not allow a draw here you could
trade Queens that's fine in fact now it
looks even a winning end game because G2
is on a light square but just play this
out play quickly do not try to find the
perfect moves try to find good enough
moves and just do not allow your last
Pawn to go he will not do that he can
place his Bishop on D7 or on B5 and now
you flag your opponent
is holding he's holding 15 says he has
six seconds here
from white
but do not oh no no he allowed a draw by
repetition and that's the one thing he
couldn't do what he missed was King to
F7 the king could have escaped because
of the white king moved up to board D7
there was a move like C5 with check so
Magnus allows Ali Reza to keep his
two-point lead and that is really bad
news for the world number one because he
can only afford to be down one point
when this match clock expires he has to
win now and you have to go for it he's
going to do it with the white pieces
here but we actually have a little bit
of a hold he takes takes
any castles queen of three three six
three six seven on
and it's gonna be annoying though
because that Rook lands on E2 and I
guess there's no time to put A5 A4
because white will push his own Pawn up
to A4 and stop that so he completes his
development by the way Rook F to B1 King
to F1 that Rook was almost trapped over
there and said The Rook is going after
those Queen side Pawns chat what do you
think is gonna happen Chad we got a
minute and 50 seconds Chad it is on you
what do you think is gonna happen is he
going to be able to do it him meaning
Magnus what do you think let's hear the
thoughts in the chat right now guys
right now we need to see it cool it's
gonna win oh man that's a
he blundered he blunt but he can afford
to draw because look at the overall
match like one minute 30 seconds remain
if he draws this then he has to win the
follow-up game and he's just letting
this one go but look at others clock
down under 20 seconds a 10 second lead
for Magnus Carlson and it looks like
objectively the game should be a draw
objectively definitely 100 15 seconds 15
seconds there for Rosa time is moving oh
what a move he wants to pass one of his
own
oh my goodness and farouza better Force
the draw now otherwise Magnus might win
this game he's going to Madison flag him
Magnus may be down two pods win on time
be Shameless
it doesn't matter how you get it it
matters if you get it done but here it
is this is the scariest part of Chess
right now this right here is scarier
than anything you've ever faced because
somebody is gonna blunder the roof
usually it happens and we see 3.5 for
alireza the thing about Magnus is he
needs to watch out because at some point
uh otherwise I might do the thing where
he puts the Rook under attack but look
at Magnus he's down to three seconds
himself he needs to move he needs to do
quick and that is a draw but Magus he he
doesn't get the win but he's 25 seconds
the last game will take place and that
means if Magnus wins we get extra time
for ruja only needs a draw
you see what's funny he goes for the G6
I don't know this is appearance but he
has to play more modern like
um in this way because he was looking at
hoping for King's Indian which is
understandable tells you a lot when you
need to win what do you go for King's
India oh okay that makes sense but at
this point this will turn into a pierce
or perk in fact with E4 and D4 he didn't
go C4 at all here very still likely to
be some type of King's Indian but it is
not the same it's not the same Magnus
needs to win chat will he do it check is
he gonna win is Magnus gonna win or not
the essential question because otherwise
this match concludes with alireza fuja
as the winner and this position looks
really good for black as he steals a
pawn in the center and Magnus ahead by
six seconds he's been faster at the
early stage of the game but in time
scrambles it's always for ruja who has
the upper hand
Magnus never got a chance to be up in
the mat I've never seen that before
actually but never got a chance
but right there that was a pretty bad
blunder from farrugia giving up the C3
pawn and here come blackspawn storming
up the board that Bishop on A8 that may
be the hero that Magnus needs oh but the
E5 pawns I thought he's gonna go E4 at
some point he drops his Central Pawn and
now Advantage back to ferrugia
time is up it is zeros This Is The
Moment of Truth here okay well Magnus oh
he's making a loser oh he's made it uh
he's even say nothing it's done
that's game that's match fine bro on
fire
with a clap there at the end you see the
gentlemanly clap and farouza he doesn't
even celebrate I mean he's still
probably feeling the adrenaline the
tension of that match